en otros vídeos ya empezamos a hablar
sobre la elasticidad precio de la
demanda y lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es pensar en los factores que
podrían hacer que la elasticidad precio
de la demanda en un mercado determinado
sea mayor o menor de modo que se podría
decir que vamos a pensar en los
determinantes de la elasticidad precio
de la demanda ahora incluso antes de que
hablemos sobre esos determinantes o
factores solo analicemos un poco cómo
sería una situación de elástica o
inelástica así que déjenme dibujar mis
ejes de precio y cantidad con los que ya
estamos muy familiarizados en este
momento entonces la cantidad va en el
eje horizontal el precio en el eje
vertical y recuerden la elasticidad
precio de la demanda es un cambio
porcentual en la cantidad derivado de un
cambio porcentual en el precio por lo
tanto una alta elasticidad sería cuando
existe un gran cambio porcentual en la
cantidad para un determinado cambio
porcentual en el precio por lo que una
alta elasticidad se vería así
sería una curva de demanda más plana lo
voy a escribir esta sería una alta
elasticidad una baja elasticidad sería
cuando el cambio porcentual en la
cantidad no cambia mucho para cierto
cambio porcentual en el precio en una
baja elasticidad o in elasticidad se
vería más acercándose a una curva
vertical entre más baja es nuestra
elasticidad por lo que la baja
elasticidad sería algo así esta es una
curva de demanda inelástica en
elasticidad en otros vídeos incluso
pensamos en una situación perfectamente
inelástica en cuyo caso tendrías una
curva de demanda totalmente vertical
pero por ahora pensemos en los factores
que podrían llevarnos a estar más cerca
del caso elástico o más cerca del caso
inelástica de modo que los factores que
los economistas determinan para una
situación sea elástica o inelástica es
que los bienes sean sustitutos en plazos
dependen de su participación en los
ingresos si el mercado del que estamos
hablando es sobre bienes de lujo o
bienes
necesarios y la definición de un mercado
así que vamos a empezar con sustitutos
imaginemos primero un mundo donde hay
muchos sustitutos para el bien o
servicio del que estamos hablando muchos
sustitutos y podemos pensar en ejemplos
para mercados de bienes o servicios
donde hay muchos sustitutos digamos que
es el mercado para las manzanas fuji
bueno los otros sustitutos son los otros
tipos de manzanas que hay por ahí las
manzanas makintouch las manzanas de
delicious y todas esas y por lo tanto
para un cambio porcentual en el precio
esperarías que la variación porcentual
en la cantidad demandada de las manzanas
fuji cambiará dramáticamente buenos y
hay muchos sustitutos y sólo las
manzanas fuji se vuelven mucho más caras
entonces la gente irá a los sustitutos
es más probable que coman las manzanas
de delicious o macintosh así que si
tienes muchos sustitutos habrá una mayor
elasticidad mayor elasticidad la
cantidad demandada supongo que se podría
decir sería muy sensible al precio
podríamos verlo al revés si tienes pocos
sustitutos pocos sustitutos bueno
entonces incluso si el precio cambio un
poco o si cambia mucho la gente no sabrá
cómo podría sustituir eso por lo que aún
podría comprar una cantidad
razonablemente similar de modo que sería
inelástica inelástico ahora qué pasa con
el plazo cómo afecta a la elasticidad
bueno imagina que estás viendo para agua
si está lloviendo ahora mismo
entonces si estás pensando en un corto
periodo de tiempo mientras llueve es
probable que los precios de los paraguas
aumenten un poco y suponiendo que haya
un gran flujo peatonal es probable que
mucha gente esté dispuesta a pagar ese
precio así que en un corto periodo de
tiempo en un periodo corto las cosas
tienden a ser inelástica inelástica
pero durante un período de tiempo más
largo un periodo más largo la gente
podría pensar que estás tratando de
aprovecharse de ellos pueden ir a otro
lugar y encontrar paraguas podrían
comprar en línea
o lo que sea de modo que las personas
tienden a ser más sensibles al precio en
un plazo más largo y pueden encontrar
sustitutos volvemos al determinante
anterior y así las cosas tienden a ser
más elásticas mayor elasticidad una vez
más podrías ver la elasticidad como cuán
sensible es la cantidad ante cambios en
el precio a continuación la
participación en el ingreso
primero pensemos en algo que representa
un porcentaje muy pequeño de tus
ingresos
digamos chicles y digamos que el chicle
ahora cuesta 25 centavos y se aumentara
a 50 centavos esto podría reducir un
poco la cantidad demandada pero puede
que no sea tan importante porque pasar
de 25 a 50 centavos no hará una gran
diferencia para la mayoría de los
bolsillos de modo que en general cuanto
menor sea la participación en el ingreso
menor participación el mercado será más
inelástico pero imagina que hay una alta
participación en los ingresos déjenme
escribir eso digamos que estamos
hablando de una
participación en los ingresos digamos
que estamos hablando de un automóvil y
si la gente ya está gastando el 20% o el
30% de sus ingresos en ese automóvil y
si el precio de ese automóvil se
duplicará viéndolo en contraste con la
subida del precio del chicle bueno la
gente ni siquiera sería capaz de exigir
las mismas cantidades que antes porque
con sus ingresos simplemente no pueden
tienen otras cosas en que gastar ese
dinero extra sus ingresos simplemente no
pueden soportarlo por lo que sería muy
sensible a los cambios en el precio de
modo que a una alta sensibilidad a los
cambios en el precio mayor elasticidad
ahora qué pasa con los bienes de lujo
frente a los bienes necesarios empecemos
por los bienes necesarios si hay algo
que definitivamente necesitas incluso si
el precio subiera un poco siempre cuando
puedas pagarlo lo conseguirías
por ejemplo hablemos de alguna medicina
digamos que eres diabético y necesitas
insulina si no consigues la insulina te
podrían pasar cosas graves
y aumentarán el precio de la insulina en
un 20 30 o 40 por ciento suponiendo que
todavía pudieras pagarla
seguirías comprando la misma cantidad
porque necesitas esa insulina y si algo
es un bien necesario bien necesario
seremos más inelásticos a cambios en los
precios la cantidad será más inelástica
el precio por lo tanto habrá
inelasticidad pero si algo es un bien de
lujo si estamos hablando de tiara de oro
y el precio del oro subió dramáticamente
bueno entonces mucha gente podría no
necesitar más una tierra de oro
realmente no va a ser una gran
diferencia en su vida entonces en
general el bien de lujo se asocia con
una mayor elasticidad ahora bien podría
haber excepciones si algo no es del tipo
de categoría de ultralujo y si tal vez
el precio aumentará quizás para la gente
que lo compra es una parte muy baja de
sus ingresos o tal vez sea una marca que
al menos para la gente que lo compra
siente que no es sustituto para él bueno
tal vez no sea tan sensible pero estamos
hablando de género
es ahora el último factor del que se
habla es de la definición del mercado de
que estamos hablando por ejemplo
podríamos estar hablando del mercado de
manzanas o podríamos hablar del mercado
de alimentos estos mercados están
describiendo los alimentos pero cuál
está mejor definido si las manzanas son
un subconjunto de todos los alimentos y
si estamos hablando del mercado de
manzanas la situación es específica si
estamos hablando de un mercado
determinado tienden a tener más
sustitutos entonces si el precio de las
manzanas sube la gente dice bueno tal
vez voy a comprar algunas peras o
plátanos o alguna otra cosa en lugar de
las manzanas y así la cantidad será más
sensible a los cambios en el precio y
tendrá una mayor elasticidad pero si
tienes una definición más amplia del
mercado el mercado de alimentos bueno
ahora los alimentos parece que son una
necesidad hay muy pocos sustitutos de
los alimentos si dejo de comer bueno no
es algo que pueda cambiar simplemente
vivir del aire o lo que sea
hay sustitutos para la comida es una
necesidad absoluta así que cuanto más
amplia es la definición del mercado
mercado más amplio tendemos a tratar con
una demanda más inelástica inelástica
hasta el próximo vídeo